with the release of Shazam Warner
Brothers has another superhero hiss on
its hands further proving that you don't
have to make your movie parts of the MCU
to have a good time
but while the movies ending is pretty
straightforward there are enough head
scratching and surprising moments in the
movies last third that might be in need
of some explanation don't sweat it
that's why we're here let's say the
magic words
spoilers ahead and explain the ending of
Shazam if you're not a longtime comic
book reader you may have scratched your
head at some of the superhero names
Billy and Freddie came up with over the
course of the film from Thunder crack to
the red cyclone none of them seem to
stick by the end of the film at the big
dude in red played by Zachary Levi never
seemed to actually get the kind of code
name that gets attached to other
superheroes you'd think after so many
attempts at getting him a code name he'd
do better than Shazam and Amy can never
say without losing his powers in a bolt
of lightning so what's the deal the
short version is that the superhero we
meet in Shazam didn't always go by this
name in fact he used to go by Captain
Marvel back when he first debuted in
1939 but years later while Captain
Marvel Comics weren't being published
timely comics changed its name to the
more familiar Marvel Comics we all know
and love
after Marvel created his own Captain
Marvel character in 1967 DC and Marvel
Comics had to come to an agreement about
how to navigate the tricky trademarks
eventually in 2011 DC just gave up
Captain Marvel entirely and simply
renamed the character Shazam so if you
were wondering why he never settled on a
pretty good name of sparkle fingers well
now you know why the final battle with
dr. sivana and the seven deadly sins
provided one of the most awesome
climactic moments in recent superhero
movie history
when Shazam extends his powers to his
foster siblings and creates five more
superheroes to save the day now instead
of one new superhero joining the DC EU
there are actually six if you wondered
how and why the movie could justify
pulling five super rabbits out of its
magical hats there's actually a pretty
nice set up for this final act twist
earlier in the film you might have
missed if you weren't paying close
attention when Billy encounters the
wizard Shazam the old
yells about the empty chairs behind him
on the rock of eternity chairs that once
belonged to his brothers and sisters and
magic who have all long since died when
Billy shares his powers he's felling
five more of those seats though just who
will be widening up sitting in that
seventh chair is a question we probably
won't have answered until the next film
however since the film seemed to pretty
closely followed the plot of DC's new 52
Shazam miniseries there's a good bet
that the current run of Shazam comics DC
is publishing will offer some clues as
to the 7th chasms identity or it could
be hoppy the Marvel Bunny okay probably
not but speaking of hidden identities
their very last scene before the credits
rolled offered up a really fun moment
when Billy's special guest Superman
makes an appearance of his own of course
while the audience saw Superman's blue
super suit the shot was conspicuously
composed to keep the actors head out of
frame considering that Superman is one
of the most popular and important
superheroes ever created it might have
seemed weird to the average moviegoer
that the filmmakers went out of their
way to not show their most bankable
hero's face the answer is that there's
some drama going on behind the scenes at
Warner Brothers and DC films regarding
just who is going to wear the big blue
suit going forward the most recent actor
to take the role of Superman Henry
Cavill is reportedly in talks with
Warner Brothers about whether or not to
return to play the character in future
movies but while cavils future a
Superman is murky the filmmakers still
wanted to have a Superman cameo in their
film so they did the next best thing
they hired a buff dude to put on the
suit while simply keeping his face out
of frame the moment in the film lands is
pretty funny even if you don't know
about Henry's alleged contract disputes
and it's even funnier if you do and say
it also meant they didn't have to spend
their CGI budget on cavils mustache so
it's a win-win one of the reasons Shazam
is so much fun is that it's an
exceptionally weird movie it's got a
magic wizard who lives in a cave the
physical embodiments of religious
concepts and an unexplained obsession
with Tigers but weirdest of all it's got
a talking evil worm who shows up in the
film's mid-credits scene in Doctor
sivanna's prison cell
ranting about seven realms as with so
many elements of superhero movies
there was probably a sizable portion of
the audience that saw this and couldn't
be more confused don't feel bad
this little guy is pretty bizarre and
obscure even for comic book fans let's
just dig into this thing the little
talking bug is a longtime chasm villain
named mr. mind he's a talking
super-intelligent worm from another
planet that planet is sometimes Venus
depending on which comic books you're
reading he's a founder of a team of
super villains and the comics called the
monster Society of evil which has
included members with names like jeepers
and mr. banjo
just to name a few it's it's pretty wild
as for the seven realms this seems like
it refers to a pretty recent addition to
the pages of DC Comics Shazam series as
of the making of this video the comics
are only starting to dig into what these
realms are or their significance so if
you want to know more about what's
likely to happen in the sequel to Shazam
start reading Shazam not only seems to
have plenty of potential for sequel
starring Billy Batson Freddy Freeman and
the rest of the Shazam family but it
also easily connects to the wider DC
extended universe
Aquaman from 2018 proved that DC movies
don't have to be grim and brooding but
2019 Shazam took things to the next
level and showed that DC Comics movies
can have strong connections to each
other without being bogged down in
cinematic universe setup and continuity
nonsense meanwhile there's tons of setup
for future interactions with other DC
heroes we already caught a partial
glimpse of Shazam teaming up with
Superman in the Fawcett central lunch
room the second post credit scene hints
are another possible team-up what could
we do with that I don't know maybe a
commander an army of billions in the
ocean oh yeah Bob Warner Brothers and
thousand lee stumbled out of the gate
with their early efforts in terms of
overall critical reception and box
office performance
Aquaman and Shazam seem to have fully
right at the ship it remains to be seen
whether or not the forthcoming slate of
DC movies will actually have any
connections to this film but if Warner
Brothers can find a way to take the
lessons of Shazam and make Superman
Batman and the rest of the gang fun
again well we'll be in for a pretty
super bunch of movies check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you